alors vous avez tous des questions et je
vous dis ce que vous allez voir dans
cette interview c'est complètement
dingue on a halluciné avec la production
vraiment des révélations qui a pu faire
nous qui a pu nous faire le procurant
déjà merci à lui vraiment d'avoir
répondu à nos questions et d'avoir
répondu positivement à notre demande
d'interview
valérie bénaïm vous avez posé une
question oui aux procureurs qu'elle
était première question qu'ils avaient
qui avait-il dans l'ordinateur de
christian quesada et il nous a répondu
le cnar d'erreur de la république déjà
première question en vol et nous a
répondu à cette question
regarde selon les enquêteurs c'est
plusieurs milliers de l'image qu'ils ont
été répertoriés sont pas tous de la même
gravité mais il ya des images clairement
ce sont des viols d'enfants de moins de
dix ans qui sont photographiés et qui
sont ensuite diffusés à des personnes
qui se complaisent devant le vent ce
type d'image alors voilà il les a
répondu donc il y à bien
donc dans son ordinateur ce genre de
vidéos comme il vient d'en parler gilles
où vous le saviez alors oui c'est une
j'ai appris grâce à l'interview mais
c'est une cellule spécifique spécialisés
de la gendarmerie de lyon qui s'occupe
de l'enquète ils veulent aussi savoir
s'il ya eu d'autres mineurs qui auraient
été c'est leur terme harponné par
christian quesada pour voir s'il est
fait pour être encore plus grave et
surtout ils se sont aperçus que
christian quesada a mis longtemps à être
repérés parce que ils avaient réussi à
utiliser des adresses fictives qui
n'était pas à son nom qu'il bloquait au
fur et à mesure donc ils ont mis très
longtemps à forcer les portes d'entrée
l'ordinateur donc et préméditation
jean michel maire vous avez posé une
question en question au procureur
oui ce cri tition quesada pour sa
défense a avoué tout de suite aux
enquêteurs qu'il est étonné qu'ils
diffusaient des images
pédopornographiques mais au dessus du
dic n'était jamais passé à l'acte pour
jouer savoir s'il procure à des
informations sur ceux sur ce passage
direct ou par votre question c'était
christian quesada et il passe à la
rivière passe à l'acte et il a répondu
également assez compliqué répondu à
toutes nos questions certes fonctions
pour l'instant il n'est pas mise en
examen
pour des faits d'agressions de viol sont
les majors sur les mineurs donc
juridiquement le
magistrat instructeur et les enquêteurs
ne travaille pas sur ces hypothèses
si au cours des investigations destinées
à identifier des personnes avec qui il a
une antenne échanger des fichiers etc
on m'apprend qu'éventuellement il ya pu
avoir des faits d'agressions à ce moment
là les avis de nouvelles investigations
pendant pourront être effectués alors
est-ce que la réponse vous convient jean
michel ben oui c'est vrai qu'ils sont en
train d'étudier il ya tellement il y
avait un ordinateur je crois avec des
mines et des milliers d'imagés et de
vidéos oh ça prend énormément de temps
et c'est de le disséquer sa d'essayer de
voir qui sont les personnes qui sont
impliquées dans l'histoire donc ça prend
du temps la vaysse question va durer
longtemps et pour l'instant il a
officiellement avoué effectivement avoir
recelé toutes ces images
pédopornographiques mais il a toujours
nié
le passage à l'acte est toujours gilles
verdez vous avez posé une question oui
monsieur le procureur est ce que
christian quesada fait partie ou non mes
rêveries en mai 4 ces mecs crois que ça
duplex alors un moment ce label est ce
que christian quesada fait partie d'un
réseau pédophile
regardez ça c'est difficile de dire s'il
fait partie
réseau mais à partir du moment où il ya
un échange de ces images qui sont encore
une fois interdites par la loi les
personnes avec qui il échange on peut
considérer que c'est un réseau après
est-ce que c'est un réseau organisé
structuré ou est-ce que c'est au hasard
des connexions que on a des échanges ce
genre de fichier
c'est des investigations ultérieures qui
éventuellement des terminaux satisfait
de la réponse très satisfait je voulais
juste insister sur le côté événementiel
de cette interview s'installera au coeur
il ya trois ans maintenant à bourg en
bresse et était à chalon avant son
créneau c'est la loi rien que la loi il
est très sérieux où l'alarmé il est
réputé pour être totalement street qui
ne dévie pas et on verra après cette
affaire alors benjamin castadi vous avez
souhaité lui opposer une toile parce que
la sphère en question la fac et date de
est ce qu'on connaît les relations
qu'ils auraient pu via l'ordinateur
en fait alors vous voulez vous vouliez
savoir quels contenus obtenus des
messages entre christian quesada et son
accusatrice puisqu'il lui demandait
apparemment de se dévêtir de lui envoyer
des photos dénudées et lui a fait des
propositions ouvertement sexuel le
procureur a également répondu à cette
question a priori messages ou des
panneaux et puis à un moment donné
c'était ouvertement des propositions
sexuelles soit le demandant de se
dénuder soit le demandant de lui envoyer
des photos c'est donc là lorsque le
le dialogue a pris à caractère sexuel a
parlé à ses parents autour d'elle et
c'est ainsi que la plainte a été déposée
ça qui est perverse
elle a quand même dire qu'à mon avis
l'iceberg il est très très très
l'argentine fait pour l'instant afin de
tirer un fil et visiblement plus les
jours passent et plus les semaines
passent plus les charges
vous êtes sûr vous êtes sur des
informations également voilà vous peut
pas les divulguer pour l'instant mais
dans les prochains jours peut-être qu'on
pourra les divulguer benjamin ces
grosses révélations gros scandale
isabelle vous avez souhaité poser
oui on a beaucoup parlé ici du passé
judiciaire de christian quesada comme il
est au coeur du serrage un bien qui nous
précise le passé judiciaire de christian
qui savent a fait une belle émission
voilà que cela a déjà été condamné il a
des antécédents judiciaires
y a que deux condamnations mais c'est
déjà suffisant c'est en partie ce qui a
motivé la conspiration de l'intéressé
les condamnations effectivement ce qu'on
a dépensé en 2001 et en 2009 l'une pour
exhibition sexuelle et l'autre pour
détention d'image de nous prendre
l'afrique c'est tout j'ai eu nos
collègues journalistes de la voix de
l'un qu'un hebdomadaire près de bourg en
bresse qui suit ou et mystérieux et ils
m'ont expliqué que christian quesada
selon leurs sources savait que les
enquêteurs étaient sur sa piste n'a pas
été surpris au moment de son arrestation
alors justement raymond a demandé
comment s'est déroulée l'arrestation
moi c'est ça que je veux savoir parce
que je me dis depuis mai 2010 est cette
jeune fille a déposé plainte on l'arrête
en mars en nous expliquant que parce
qu'il avait fait des jeux télé on air on
a eu du mal à la trappe et moi c'est ça
je vais savoir comment s'est déroulé son
arrestation
regardez l'interpellation s'est déroulée
une commission dans la mesure où les
enquêteurs savaient qu'ils n'avaient pas
à faire 1 1
dangereux criminels ils sont allés tout
simplement à son domicile seront
interpellées l'ont conduit dans les
locaux de la gendarmerie et ont signifié
les raisons pour éviter les têtes en
garde à vue ils ont modifié les droits
qu'il avait d'être examinée par un
médecin le faire prévenir quelqu'un de
sa famille doivent être assistées par un
avocat des droits qui sont attachés à la
statue de garde à vue et ensuite les
enquêteurs ont commencé lors d'intermat
quoi alors justement géraldine notre
question elle suit rsa suis absolument
la question vraiment sais quoi et moi
christian quesada s'est il comporté face
aux policiers
alors elle a été sa réaction alors il
j'ai vu un tweet alors c'est qu'ils
étaient très drôles ils ont dit qu
encore une fois il a répondu à toutes
les questions peuvent regarder je vous
dise ce qu'il a reconnu les faits qu'il
a pas eu beaucoup de difficultés les
avoués
il a d'autant moins de difficultés à
désavouer que les preuves étaient là les
consultations sur ces ordinateurs
étaient des preuves matérielles qu'il ne
pouvait pas contester et donc il a admis
les faits sans trop s'en trouve
difficulté alors là il va être en
détention il est en détention provisoire
et justement on a souhaité savoir
combien de temps il va rester en
détention provisoire
regardez la réponse du procureur dans
son provisions on sait quand ça commence
mais on sait pas toujours quand elle se
termine
elle peut durer jusqu'au jour du
jugement c'est à dire qu'à ce moment là
l'intéressé comparaît détenu à
l'audience où les juges et où la liberté
enfin libération peut intervenir en
cours de dossiers en cours d'instruction
si le juge d'instruction estime
que finalement il est plus nécessaire
pour le bon déroulement de l'enquêté
pour la manifestation de la vérité qui
n'est plus nécessaire que l'intéressé
soit détenu eh bien il peut être remis
en liberté sous contrôle judiciaire
décrit un certain obligation de pointer
à tel ou tel endroit d avoir des
obligations qui vont restreindre un peu
la liberté du mis-en-cause sans pour
autant qu'ils sont 10 alors vous avez
donc et on sait il nous a répondu aussi
il paraît que l' enquête durerait entre
six mois et un an
elle va durer entre six mois et un an
oui gens me le procure le dit pas là
mais je pense que les enquêteurs
pourraient nous le dire c'est que
l'arrestation d'une personne comme plus
stocker sa paye toujours délicat parce
que contrairement aux gangsters pour qui
la prison fait toujours partie de leurs
du potentiel de hip hop ça peut toujours
se passer et ne savent très bien les
gens comme question que ceux là qui sont
accusés de pédophilie
souvent ils veulent mettre fin à leurs
jours mon arrestation donc nous obliger
à révéler prendre par surprise pour
éviter qu'ils se fassent justice
eux-mêmes pour complice justement faire
justice pour les victimes
alors après on aura justement on peut en
venir déçu parce que c'est sûr là la
question de quelle île il voulait dire
quelque chose juste un mot concernant sa
défense ce qu'il faut noter et qui est
étonnant c'est que pour l'instant il a
une avocate de bourg-en-bresse qu'était
une avocate commise d'office c'est à
dire que c'est pas quelqu'un qui l'a
choisie est d'accord et pourtant il a
les moyens financiers assure l'avocate
ya encore quelques heures
s'interrogeait pour savoir s'ils
allaient continuer à suivre le dossier
ou si christian quesada les choisir un
autre avocat en tout cas la bonne info
il a demandé une remise en liberté pour
laquelle attente du procès c'est ce
qu'elle alors justement christian
questionner vous avez placé justement
j'aurais voulu savoir s'il a vu un
traitement particulier en raison de sa
notoriété
il nous a répondu le procureur regardez
c'est clair peut-être vu décevoir tout
le monde mais le fait que le dire et c
sont connus
ça n'a aucune incidence sur l' enquête
ça n'arrange ni plus facile ni plus
difficile
la seule différence est dans les suites
qui sont données à cette interpellation
à cette mise en examen
les suites sont médiatisés attise la
curiosité tout le monde mais sur le
déroulement de l'enquète sur la réunion
des indices sur la constitution des
preuves sur les questions qui ont été
posées par le juge d'instruction que
l'intéressé soit connue pas connus qui
sont en riches aux pauvres ça ne change
strictement rien à faire
jardine son compte twitter n'a pas
encore été fermées il est sous séquestre
ça s'appelle sous scellés numérique avec
m perez donc on est en train d'éplucher
tous sont passés numérique pour voir
s'il ya des images des tiges yeux zoo
des choses un peu compliquées
ainsi on est en train de nous dire c'est
que là on a demandé la remise en liberté
de crise en quesada oui moi je trouve
sidérant c'est la loi d'accord j'ai que
j'y connais rien aux lois mais je trouve
ça sidérant attendons de voir ce qu'on
va trouver déjà pendant deux ans ils ont
enquêté et là on dit moi on veut on peut
leur en mettre dehors
bon de te le donne en temps ça fait
bizarre et valérie par ailleurs d'après
les différents jurys ce qu'on a pu avoir
ils nous disent que cette demande de
libération en attendant le procès ne
sera certainement pas accédé d'accord
alors justement on a demandé aussi aux
procureurs comment il vit la
médiatisation de cette affaire
voilà c'est vrai que il a répondu par la
positive donc à notre demande
d'interview regarde normalement
médiatique qui se produit autour de
cette affaire est de nature non
seulement le déstabiliser mais peut-être
le plonger dans une profonde dépression
qui pourrait l'amener à voir des gestes
irréversible donc il convient quoiqu'il
n'ait pu faire et quoi qu'on puisse lui
reprocher convient quand même un pommier
qu'il s'agit d'un homme et que
il faut le protéger y compris contre
lui-même
et n'oublions pas que christian quesada
a deux petits garçons oui exactement
alors après avoir après on va voir la
question de jean michel parce que ça
concerne tf1 juste mercredi les 12 coups
de midi avait réuni 3,4 millions de
téléspectateurs
il s'agissait de la dernière émission
avant la révélation du scandale
christian queffelec depuis les audiences
ont un peu baissé l'émission de jean-luc
reichmann a réuni 3 millions de
téléspectateurs
ils ont perdu 300000 téléspectateurs est
ce qu'on pensait scellier ou pas du tout
faut le voir sur la longueur ça on va
avoir sur la longueur mais bon il força
en forçant c'est vraiment fort par
exemple personnellement en attendant que
l' affaire soit réglée qui est une issue
judiciaire sans doute je ne regarde plus
les missions je vous le dis c'est que
moi mais pour quel rapport non mais je
vous ai mon point de vue téléspectateurs
il pour moi elle est impactée elle est
marquée par ailleurs jean luc reichmann
a très vite réagi en solidarisant en
expliquant qui est tombé de sa chaise et
qu'il était absolument 1er tri par ça
donc je vois pas bien je pense que les
téléspectateurs ont beaucoup des
lanceurs pour iceman ne vont pas le dr
jean-michel que sont michel tu le
veuille ou pas cette affaire un peu
cassé le jouet quand même a cassé brisé
le rêve comme le disait raymond faire de
la même façon quelle histoire
d'agression sexuelle supposée donc au
long de l'année dernière à casser un peu
le nid de commentaires alors on va voir
la dernière question justement jean
michel vous l'avez demandé au procureur
si c'était par une sono actionnaires
regarder y a pas plus de raisons de
sanctionner qui que ce soit ou de
reprocher quoi que ce soit à des
organismes à partir du moment où ils la
respectent la loi a repris de justice
même condamné une peine criminelle
une fois qu'il a purgé sa peine pour
parfaitement être employé dans une
entreprise
ce ne sont pas des gens banni à vie ce
sont pas des parias les 23 réinsérer
dans la société et à ce titre ils sont
des citoyens comme tout le monde
voilà donc la mia répondu à toutes les
questions merci à monsieur le procureur
en tout cas d'avoir à toutes nos
questions